les gars allez c'est arrivé j'ai appris
qu'un type de la formation prenait sa
retraite à la fin de la saison là au
moins je fasse vraiment partie du club
quand est ce que tu fais là qui est
important pour nous d'aller ou choisir
de robocop et pour vous que je fais ça
les gars comme ça vous rester focus sur
le foot
même si je voulais je pourrais pas te
rentrer dans club pas s'afficher comme
ça bon que tu es qui toi au final pas
dire que je vais sur les intérêts du
club des joueurs
et qui comme toi j'en vois défiler
toutes les semaines tu vois et c'est
quoi les filles comme moi j'ai vu vos
exploits dans la presse bravo travail
merci ce que je me suis tanné pot commun
[Musique]
lorna l'alaska dernière
ce serait à vie pour toi qu'on les
reprenne les footeux partie vaut mieux
ça parce que ta vie est tout à fait
rêver peut-être ta boîte battre monnaie
ta vie tous les week-ends sur le terrain
ils font toujours le petit truc qui te
sépare celui qui réussit le pitbull
c'est comme ça qu'on l'appelait à
l'époque
plus personne ne l'appelle comme ça
maintenant
[Musique]
ce que tu fous avec un tocard pareil
côté jamal et tenter ta chance ailleurs
c'est ma ville c'est mon club
qu'est ce que tu fais fin j'ai un opéra
je me confiant ça va bien se passer